Now, I'd like you to use one
assistive technology and
complete a task with one of your
favorite mobile apps or websites.
If you're using Mac,
you can open System Preferences and
then click on Accessibility.
You might try to invert colors or
use grayscale or
you could play around with these other
options, such as Zoom and Voiceover.
As you use one of
the accessibility tools,
I'd like you to answer
the following questions.
Can you find all of
the critical content?
Can you navigate the page or
the application and
find the links that you want?
And finally, can you actually
complete the chosen task?
This will help you get into
the mindset of your users and
develop empathy for them.
You'll get a quick sense about which
products are accessible and useable for
most users and which ones aren't.
Once you've done this task,
check this box to continue.